thanks to the organizers great to be
here so you love well friends I am I
arrived here at 5am New York time
because my flight was delayed so I have
some nice English breakfast tea to it in
spite of the four hours of sleep to give
it go here and talk and I'm going to
tell you about some recent work we've
been doing on the developing new
algorithms for analyzing high-throughput
protein-dna interactions and ateh from
selects experiments and this is a
collaboration with Richard men and the
reamer rose we have a grunt together to
do this work and I'm going to start by
just pointing to a paper from almost ten
years now ago the me tell me paper by
miracle and quake where they use micro
fluidics to measure kds for for large
number of sequences and what you see
here is actually super fine the pointer
is the full raw data for two different
helix-loop-helix pro sugar factory from
yeast it happens but it doesn't really
matter there are different factors and
this is on a log scale the the KD order
defining free energy for different
sequences and what what they did in this
paper is they use only this in vitro
measurements combine it with the human
art with the yeast genome all the
promoter sequences to predict which
genes are the targets of these two
different for sugar vectors one at a
time and then when they got their top
targets and they scored for enrichment
of gene ontology categories and actually
hear the same color is used for very
different goal calories in panel a and B
so maybe the point is that these are
very different from these you know even
though the top category is green the
view you know keep that in mind it's
very amazing if you think of it this if
you look at these profiles it's pretty
much the same for both records they like
to buy to an e box right there some
differences but if you eyeball these
profiles you would say they kind of have
the same preferences right but if you
use these data in a quantitative way
with the actual genome sequence and
nothing else no empirical measurements
of gene expression or or binding just
the genome sequence and these affinities
and then try to predict what genes are
you get qualitatively different
predictions and what kind of pathways
are controlled by these two factors
from these quantitative subtle
differences between these factors and
that's what motivates a lot of of our
researchers is to try and capture these
subtle but important functional
differences between close paralogs of
tribute vectors from the same family and
see if we can you know by doing rigorous
modeling of of the high-throughput day
that we can actually capture those
functional differences just in terms of
the in vitro binding specificity of
those vectors and over the last years
we've been working a lot with the type
of selects data you know we call select
seek which uses MC gels which are
different from doing solution based
measurements such as an HT selection
that you can isolate complexes of say
heterodimer for should be factors
binding to DNA right you start with the
random pool you sequence that then you
cut out the bound DNA from the MC jail
after a round of selection you can
actually iterate this but you can also
do just one round and then you sequency
the selected pool as well and from the
statistical differences between those
two pools you can somehow you know do
motif discovery right now what we did in
this paper which was paper with with
remo and Richard and baryonic at the
time we developed a method for camera
and Richmond this is a former postdoc in
the lab Todd Riley and this has actually
recently been reimplemented very
efficiently by grad City my lab
Chaitanya rastogi and it's a buyer
conducted package that Dusty's in
seconds on on the macbook air but you
can basically count k-mers in your
ground zero pool and in the selected
pool and then scored on Richmond
normalize it to a score from zero to one
right so every camera gets an enrichment
score the best but highest affinity
camer gets a score of one background
binding is close to zero right and you
can summarize the experiment this way
what is the drawback of this is that you
know each camera is scored independently
right so you don't capture the
relationships between I scammers
actually different shifted versions of
them and ideally you would like to
understand the relationship between
these cameras in terms of features such
as you know base
the presence of an a at some position or
even base parameters like the ones that
the dream o's been really focusing on
and make making us all aware of so in
general you would like to model
protein-dna interactions with some kind
of biophysical model in terms of the
concentration of the protein and a KD
that you know it's the binding models
that the interaction the strength of the
interaction between between the protein
and the DNA and if you have some optimal
sequence you make a mutation you get a
changing the affinity that's basically e
to the power the difference in free
energy right and of course you know
there's sequences in the genome that are
more than one mutation away from the
optimal side and if you want to model
those you have to make an assumption
that maybe you can add up the free
energy contributions from those
different features that you perturb and
this can be generalized to dinucleotides
or you know include DNA shape parameters
as well right so if you this is just a
little overview of some approaches to
trying to fit such a base feature based
models for protein binding microarray
data such as the type that Martha book
swap is we pioneered right if you can
restore mo a long time ago right already
did regression modeling of measured kds
I did measure Katie's with with M cells
and then they try to explain those those
the variation in cadia over sequences in
terms of base features a basically fit
Delta Delta G like parameters with
linear regression and then you know 20
years later my lab formulated algorithm
were basically model the PBM intensities
as a sliding windows some of such a
model over the PBM probes and then more
recently it has been tailored both in
gary's lab and mind and by other people
as well the 222 model PBM data and
capture some of the positional
dependencies there right but the idea is
that you can refer these Delta Delta G
like parameters from the data by fitting
this nonlinear model to to do
raw data using the data from all the
pros at the same time now if you think
of where we are with the you know
equivalent or analog development of
algorithms for SELEX feature based
models of the Sonics so far with very
successful applications for instance by
iremos lab with martha boo luke and
we've been literally involved with that
as well where if you know where the
binding window is you know and so you
can basically align sequences and then
you get a score of their enrichment from
these camera table like approaches you
can try to detect that in terms of of
bays and shape features and then it
gives very good insights what is not
captured yet is the fact that of course
the factor can bind anywhere in the cell
x-pro right and so so doing something
analogous to taking the sum over the
whole probe and then fitting these
parameters that's something we've been
working on very actively in the last
couple of years and I want to show you
the results from two different
algorithms one of which is a an
approximate algorithm and that is
implemented in our and if we've used for
a couple different I'm just trying to
make sure I understand previous slides
of the church I just get basically just
the partition function 41 inches physics
yeah well the sum is actually sliding
windows some overviews on the single
sequence right so observation well
that's an approximation in the sense
that there's no saturation of binding
right so the average number of protein
molecules bound to the longer DNA
sequences the first order is the sum of
the affinities I is l voix files are
features friends is having an a a
position three or two minor groove with
that position five all right so the idea
is that the total free energies to sum
over all these features and then a
coefficient that measures the effect
size where every features and now you
can exponentiate that you get an
affinity or a Boltzmann factor so
depending on whether you take the log or
not it's either additive and
multiplicative but that's that's you
know
yeah these windows are overlapping
because in Princeton well we look at
every window every possible view on the
sequence because the idea is that the
concentration is the protein is low
enough that that most of the time
there's just one protein bound to the
sequence you can actually with transfer
matrix methods you can you know deal
exactly what you know with with the
situation where when there's when you
have some situation in competition with
between different binding sites and but
but that's computationally more you know
intensive but it doesn't really get you
a lot in terms of performance of the
methods so of course you know if you
have a sum you can take the log to go
from a sum to a product right and so it
doesn't matter in this case but if you
have a sum of a product which really
this is you know e to the power to some
of these for energy contributions then
it's a harder computational problem I
think you need a fancier algorithms to
do that so the first approach that we
developed reading by gabriela martina in
my lab and in collaboration with you dat
criminal Bauer who is also doing a lot
of experiments in the lab which is
really taking these methods and while
they are still being developed and
applying them getting very interesting
results and we're actually working on a
package now that makes is available to
other people and it builds on the
bioconductor package for constructing
these camera tables efficiently than we
dealer that we already published this
assumes there's one dominant binding
site per probe right and then you can
kind of go back to to the previous
situation but it's no the alignment is
based on the affinity model not based on
some kind of sequence feature okay and
what is what is important about this is
that it allows you to go over much
larger ranges of base identity than the
camer models why do the cons okay MERS
in the selects pool they decreases 1
over 4 to the power in okay the length
of the camera so so there's a limit to
how far you can go and in practice it's
about no 12 base pairs right but if you
have such a feature based model there's
no reason why you couldn't go over much
larger footprint to model how
affinity depends on the on the
underlying sequence you still have to
see this with with some you know it's a
most average gamer but then after that
it becomes a self-consistent problem but
the first application of this is
something that we've been working on in
collaboration with mouse poo file and is
grad student liang zhang mouth and then
have been using select seek on the
imogen and the glucocorticoid receptor
if you look at the crystal structure of
the AR in a gr and you look at where the
differences are in the amino acid
identities at the interface with the DNA
there's very little difference right so
and also the consensus in the field is
that these factors bind to a 15 base
pair binding site that's kind of the
same for the different family members by
AR and g are at the same intrinsic
specificity is the is the belief and any
difference in their function is coming
from cofactors that are specific to
maybe do one of those thank you now if
you look at their data with this kind of
relative entropy got a measure that we
used in a salary paper you see that
there's a hint that there's a difference
that there's you know over a larger
range of base pairs there's information
for the AR a larger range than for the
glucocorticoid receptor and I don't want
to really explain this because I'm going
to show the results in a more refined
way right now this shows infer Delta
Delta G's free energy parameters for all
the possible base substitutions single
base substitutions for the antigen
receptor and what you see airs on the
two axes is these Delta Delta G's as
inferred from two different rounds of
the selects data that are independent of
each other and we have error bars on the
above Delta G's and you can see that
within the error pretty much it's very
reproducible between rounds so that's
nice we can actually you know put
confidence values on the infrared free
energies parameters and if you look in
the flanks this is basically e to the
power delta g right so this is the
exponential version of these skills over
here if you show them as an energy logo
we're basically read off the sequence
here and the skills of free energy skill
this is actually something we introduced
when we publish the matrix reduce
algorithm and you know we like it I
think so other people also starting to
use it now what you see here is that
there's a difference between the flanks
outside of this 15 base pair consensus
between the AR which I'm circling here
and the gr the AR like stretches of poly
a that the GR doesn't care so much about
and if you think stretches of poly a you
think maybe the minor groove is narrowed
right even if you look at the the minor
groove with profile using Reema roses
tools across this this whole region you
see there's a dip outside of the 50 base
pair region that seems to indicate now
that there might be a minor group
interaction and if we actually use our
our model to stratify sequences based on
their affinity and then plot the mind a
group with profile for different levels
of affinity you see this continuous
trend that the more high affinity
sequences that shown in red here they
have this dip and if you go down and
infinity through the lower affinity
sites you lose that preference for the
foreign aromatic group does that might
agree with like how pretty good yeah I
know this is this is just from his table
d initiate okay so of course you know
you can make a observational I kiss in
your model but you want to validate it
and so one way in which miles and Lee
unvalidated this by doing isothermal
kalermen t and measurements of you know
for this complex and so detailed
measurements of separately entropy and
enthalpy change for a couple of
different DNA sequences that either had
or did not have these poly a tails and
the nice thing is that because you can
separately estimate the the entropic and
the enthalpy effects and mayra goofy the
interaction are believed to be based on
the electrostatic interaction and this
indeed shows that it's mostly driven by
enthalpy so it's consistent with like an
electrostatic readout you know in this
in the side of this binding site
consistent with it with a role for for
readout of minor groove with charges
through arginine aside change or other
positively charged side chains right so
this is like biophysical
yeah so it's not that large but if you
if you add up the Delta G's over that
whole flanking region right and then you
say what is the full difference between
the highest and lowest you know possible
flank across the possibility that's like
a well these are these are actually not
frequency this these are the Delta Delta
G primers that are fit in our model so
it's directly the regression coefficient
of this is an individual in it maybe I'm
just I'm just trying to see his visit
the time where the editing the
assumption brings down yeah but this is
definitely approximate because this is
you know we were using a single base
pair but even within the context of this
approximation there's a more than
tenfold relative preference between AR
and gr so you can design two different
sequences right and one is between those
two sequences the relative preference
between gr and AR is tenfold difference
between those two sequences even you
know within this model fit
but you can you know for individual
longer sequences right it can give you
the darker tenfold affinity difference
between the two proteins binding you
know it's like the ratio of ratios
between the two factors AR and gr and
the two different well great so you know
it's so did the full subreddit I was
trying to kind of good then not spend
too much time on this but within the 50
base pair region there are also
differences between the two factors
there are on the same order as to as the
differences in a flank right and if you
add up all those differences over the
full binding site you get to attend
Fulton okay so this is directed by a
physical follow up on this on this
prediction of the difference between the
two factors this is showing using chip
seek data from a modified prostate
cancer cell line where these two factors
are our present and you know if you if
you think about is how do you use chip
data to validate this prediction it's a
little different from like doing an ROC
curve because here we're not trying to
show that these weight matrices by
themselves are good at predicting
hormone receptor binding sites we're
trying to validate something more subtle
that the the difference between the two
models that we build for the two time
two sets of subjects data alright the
difference is biologically meaningful in
a in vivo context right so we fit a
model essentially where we you know try
to explain to the chip and Richmond the
peak height in terms of no scoring the
sequence using these two different
weight matrices and I would have shown
here is the regression coefficient for
the AR weight matrix and the grr weight
matrix and then what you would like to
see which is shown over here for the gr
chip data that all the variation in peak
height is explained by this gr right in
that they are
is as little to to add to that if you
look at the chip data for a are now we
would have been very happy if this would
be a toll turquoise bar and now / and no
orange it's not exactly that right and
we're somewhere between we're still
trying to figure out exactly what it is
but it's known that in prostate cancer
that the gr can take over from the AR
and not conversely so maybe that has
something to do with that asymmetry okay
so this is this is chip seek yeah
yeah they bind different regions and
that you know the difference between
these weight matrices is really useful
for capturing the in vivo targeting by
the studio Carmen Luna any cofactors
there are cofactors are like Fox a1
right but they're not in this I'm not
picking those into account here yeah
we're trying to see how much can we
explain just in terms of the intrinsic
binding preference or the difference
between the two factors right but of
course cofactors is ours also you know
going to be part of what in the end the
terms of this specificity so the other
algorithm that we've developed a member
right now you know try to to wrap up is
is a maximum likelihood framework that
deals with this sliding window in an
exact way and it really in a model sums
up all the possible offsets and then
tries to fit the coefficient for all the
features this is numerically your heart
problem for instance of deep learning
methods are more likely the previous
algorithm right but if you have this
kind of mix of summing and taking
products it took a while to get this on
the control even though conceptually
it's pretty simple but numerically to
make it work it was actually not
straightforward the nice thing is we can
just start with all the Delta Delta G is
equal to zero maybe fit of weight matrix
or add shape parameters and then we just
go downhill in the log likelihood
function and we'll get our model fit and
just to show how this works for on the
Slattery data you know the Hawks XD data
from our paper with Richard men and remo
and barely a couple years ago and this
is actually a crystal structure a nice
rendering of it crystal structure from
Joshi at all by paranoia in rainbows lab
you see the EXT cofactor here in complex
with the hawks protein ser in this case
right and what's happening here in the
middle of the of the binding site is
that these arginine side chains
positively charged that are interacting
with a minor groove here
and what I'm showing here in the next
slide is model fit using is a
maximum-likelihood framework of a single
base pair base feature model together
with a coefficient for minor groove with
readout across this binding site and
what you see here is a fit to the
monomer data which actually part of the
Slattery paper but with the monomer data
because the motif is sure they're not
very information content rich it's
actually hard to do the alignment of the
sequencer you know the only way to
analyze this data is with this kind of
model that we developed and so you can
see here is you line up this monomer
motif from our fit with the fit on the
on the on the heterodimer data you know
you can this this is really modeling how
the hawks protein itself is interacting
with DNA and the corresponding shape
fits together with the error bars and we
also have error bars on the on the
leather hides if you like in this model
fit right what you see is what happens
in the context of the heterodimer that
there is a suddenly a strong preference
for a narrow minded growth layer in
between the two homeo domains which is
you know consistent with what we've seen
in the crystal structure and also what
we previously reported in these papers
that we publish what are actually the
features that are in this sort of
effective energy model very different
position yes there are additional thing
what are the additional it's so it's
whether you have a certain letter at
some position relative to the footprint
of the factor at and it could be a shape
parameter like minor groove width at
every position within the binding site
over an arbitrary range those two things
okay yeah that's it
because I wanted to wrap up by by
showing some data or result also for EXT
hogs in this case for the for its this
is actually a complex with with the
formed I think yeah here we go and this
experiment was done by Judith crib Obama
in my lab and we we got to this
conclusion using some of the the the glm
approximate methods that we developed
with Gabriella and this really came out
of a project on full length home with
Oryx where you know if you see here's a
third protein that in a different splice
form has a homeodomain so you really get
three different homeo domains that are
forming a complex together and we we've
done a lot of work on this that you're
this is going to present the Cold Spring
Harbor and next week but like a site a
result of this project was pretty
striking is that when we use this to
analyze the binding by this complex we
discovered that the n-terminal arm of
exd so not of hawks in the previous
crystal structure I was showing how the
n-terminal arm of the Hawks protein is
weeding out the minor groove to the left
of the Hawks domain and that's in
between the two homeo domains over here
right but now what you see in this
picture is that this the n-terminal arm
of of extra identical is also reading
out to buying a groove here outside of
the wind considered to be the complete
binding site / 12 base pairs and the
interesting thing is that it would never
come out of the the analysis that we've
done so far because they were limited to
this horizon of 12 base pairs and what
what the model fits told us that there
there was a minor groove with read out
here to the left of the extra identical
domain so that the n-terminal arm not
only of the Hawks protein but also have
extra tentacle which is binding with
hawks in a kind of 10m configuration was
also reading out minor groove width here
you see that the interaction in a in a
crystal structure and the striking thing
was that if you mutate this argument
which is something that the Judah did
and she even ran select seek follow-up
experiment using
is mutant proteins in it you know when
the third home you know may was present
but if the homeodomain is not there of
how follow thorax the third factor this
mutation of the arginine in the internal
are completely kills binding of the EXT
hugs dimer and what you seen as gel is
the effect of a couple of different
mutations to the exd protein and in the
right column here is the asparagine 51
which is the core residue that
recognizes the 80 of the homeodomain the
alpha 3 helix which completely kills
binding if you mutate either arginine 5
or arginine two in the n-terminal arm
that also completely kills by which was
completely unexpected for us right and
again if you have the third protein to
kind of stabilize things then you can
form a complex but the HD and hominem a
huckster protein by themselves they are
no longer able to bind to the DNA if you
even with a single base pair mutation
okay so just want to thank all the
people my lab who contributed to this
and of course our collaborators Richard
and Remo and mouse and people in their
lab and have already acknowledged the
various people my lab with the different
results thank you for your attention all
the arg el is very simple and your
models predicted by name
so Tony specificities yes I mean this
slide with the cheap people show the the
models are designed to predict
affinities right so they predict total
Delta the binding free energy ad 10 for
one by one protein and baby yeah right
so once you fit them you can add up the
coefficient for any sequence and get a
prediction of the relative affinity of
that sequence i justjust parametrized by
those features and that you know debt
itself of course it's the same all of
them raimo and Martha and look I and
everybody it's been using right and you
guys I guess right it's what is
different is the the way we estimate
those parameters I know we think we can
go for a larger range and maybe get more
accurate estimates of it as far as
capturing low affinity sites which do
the chips here how cool is the agreement
and earning ballpark so what fraction of
sites of high-affinity occupy the what
fraction occupied side yeah i think that
the standard way to compare is using ROC
curves kind of measured where you know
you say I know so that's that that's
that's good where you tells you and you
can compare different models but but
really I think it's a great question
like you want to use these motive models
to make functional predictions right and
you would want to make quantitative
predictions of what the tetras doing in
this cell so so we are actually working
on an extension of this to to fit the
chip seek data as well in a quantitative
way right and maybe that will allow us
to more directly compare these
delegation actually I won't give up
delta chi quick review jump ship I
so Delta G's of computing function
function empty actual occupants all
kinds of signs of goodbye yeah it's very
you know and we are very interested in
the question I think if you say
occupancy enrichment in a chip
experiment it's a different thing right
so and if you can only measure occupancy
in directly so that's the first problem
right and the best predictor of a chip
seek experiment for factor X in in cell
line y is the average of all the other
chips you experiments in cell on why
right so so so I think predicting actual
even a Richmond or occupancy right from
the sequence is a very hard problem I
think what we are trying to focus on
this trying to predict the relative
binding by different closely related
family members and if we can do that and
maybe use the United seek as part of
your capturing the you know the the
chromatin context or other you know
commenting markers that that would be
fine but you know I think I predicting
chips tick data from the sequence from
scratch that's is very hard problems
probably even until only one is
this is the so this says you know why
chip enrichment equals beta blue times
the affinity for sell at the AR plus
some other regression coefficient beta
orange dynasty void major score for AR
and these are the beta is from that
model all right well thanks all the
speakers from this morning session